[Musik]
ich begrüße sie sehr herzlich zu einer
neuen ausgabe von unter den linden
die kanzlerin hat es auf dem
deutschlandtag der jungen union am
wochenende durchaus selbstkritisch
eingeräumt die große koalition in berlin
beschäftigt sich viel zu sehr mit sich
selbst sacharbeit so auch die
wahrnehmung in der öffentlichkeit wurde
in vielen politikfeldern gar nicht oder
nur unzureichend geleistet es ging fast
immer ums personal und wenn es dann doch
einmal um themen ging dann dominierte
oft das thema sicherheit die debatte der
fall maßen gewalttaten und daraus
resultierende proteste und
demonstrationen zwangen die politik
diese agenda auf wie reagiert die
politik auf diese scheinbare
gesellschaftliche grundstimmung wie
begegnet sie einem gesellschaftlichen
gefühl der unsicherheit sind die
maßnahmen geeignet uns tatsächlich zu
schützen oder greifen sie zu stark in
unsere freiheitsrechte 1
dieses möchte ich heute gerne
diskutieren zum einen mit philipp amthor
mitglied der cdu csu fraktion und auch
mitglied des innenausschusses im
deutschen bundestag und mit konzerten
coole dem innenpolitischen sprecher der
fdp-fraktion im bundestag herzlich
willkommen man sie beide am tor wenn man
sich diese letzten monate noch mal so im
kopf revue passieren lässt dann könnte
man meinen unsere gesellschaft sei angst
besetzt ist das so naja wir müssen schon
ein problem zur kenntnis nehmen nämlich
dass wir einerseits objektiv den
statistiken nach wohl so sicher sind wie
seit 20 jahren nicht und gleichzeitig
merken wir aber dass das subjektive
unsicherheitsgefühl ebenfalls so groß
ist wie seit 20 jahren nicht und
deswegen stellt sich die frage auch für
uns als politiker wie geht man damit um
sagen wir jetzt den leuten die sorgen
haben ja das ist alles komplett
unberechtigt und statistisch sind sie
sicher oder sagen wir auch wir müssen
dieses angstgefühl auch ernst nehmen und
darauf antworten geben
ich glaube wir müssen letzteres tun aber
müssen uns dabei abgrenzen von
populismus aber ganz klar sagen wir sind
für einen starken und wehrhaften
rechtsstaat und machen das mit dreierlei
dingen mehr personal bessere ausstattung
und auch mehr kompetenz
dort wo es nötig ist herr coole angst
bedrohung und sicherheitsgefühl würden
sie sagen dass es auch der nährboden wo
man freiheit die beschneidung von
freiheitsrechten rechtfertigen kann
also wir leben bin unglaublich
aufgeregten zeit man muss sich nur
anschauen das in sachsen ein mensch zu
tode gekommen ist durch einen
abgelehnten asylbewerber der längst
hätte des landes verwiesen werden müssen
daraufhin hat es demonstrationen gegeben
und das hat zu einer vielzahl an fragen
geführt fragen der versammlungsfreiheit
fragen der pressefreiheit fragen der
führung des bundesamtes für
verfassungsschutz und so rutschen wir
allmählich in einen ausnahmezustand in
der debatte der immer weitere eingriffe
in die freiheitsrechte natürlich auch
rechtfertigt ich glaube immer die
bundesverfassungsrichter udo di fabio
hat mal gesagt die lust am antizipierten
ausnahmezustand ist ein schlechter
ratgeber und so empfinde ich das wir
lassen uns immer mehr bestimmen davon
wie eigentlich ein versagen der
sicherheitsbehörden wie eigentlich
schlechte sicherheitspolitik aussieht
statt einfach auch mal anzuerkennen dass
unsere sicherheitsbehörden in
deutschland in der regel einen guten job
machen gerade beispielsweise in köln
einen terroristischen anschlag
verhindert haben und diese ruhe und
diese nüchternheit im umgang mit der
inneren sicherheit das sollte unser
ratgeber sein und nicht der
ausnahmezustand der dann dazu führt dass
man permanent die grundrechte aller
bürgerinnen und bürger immer weiter
beschneidet und damit ja irgendwie auch
jeder einzelne unter generalverdacht
stellen
darauf kommen wir gleich noch intensiver
zu sprechen amthor würden sie sagen dass
den feinden der freiheit ist gelingt
tatsächlich diese liberale gesellschaft
zu unterminieren
das würde ich so nicht sagen aber es
stimmt schon dass wir uns manchmal und
das ist ein ganz wichtiger punkt fragen
müssen wie es eigentlich das klima für
unsere sicherheitsbehörden
denn in der tat ärgere ich mich dann
doch wenn ich jetzt auch an den
hambacher forst denke wenn ich noch
etwas weiter zurück denke an g 20 auch
wie mit unseren sicherheitsbehörden
umgegangen wird und welches misstrauen
man dort auch oft hat oder das beste
beispiel dafür ist natürlich der fall
hans-georg maßen wir haben gerade von
dem fall gehört des vereitelten
anschlages in köln
da muss man sagen dass es auch der
arbeit von hans georg maßen als
verfassungsschutzpräsident in der zeit
zu verdanken gewesen
und in der tat muss man den eindruck
haben der öffentlichen
die auf populisten oft schüren wollen
als dass wir sicherheitsbehörden hätten
die ihren job nicht können natürlich
gibt es defizite da müssen wir an vielen
stellen dran denken auch wenn wir uns
anschauen die nsu mord serie anderes
mehr
oder den breitscheidplatz das sind alles
dinge die wir parlamentarisch
aufarbeiten und wo es auch
innenpolitische probleme gab
aber für uns geht es darum eben bessere
rückschlüsse daraus abzuleiten und das
wichtige ist dass dass wir das signal
senden in der täglichen arbeit leisten
diejenigen die für unsere
sicherheitsbehörden arbeiten unsere
polizisten und andere mehr wirklich gute
arbeit und es ist nicht anzunehmen dass
wir hier in allzu großer unsicherheit
leben auch wenn wir die berechtigten
sorgen ernst nehmen müssen da ist was
dran alles gut aber der oberste
repräsentant der inneren sicherheit in
deutschland horst seehofer als
bundesinnenminister sollte dann auch mal
angesichts der ereignisse in chemnitz
angesichts von einer unglaublich
aufgeregten debatte in der lage sein
eine einheitliche kommunikationslinie in
seinem geschäftsbereich festzulegen
bundespolizei bka und auch das bundesamt
für verfassungsschutz stattdessen
arbeitet sich herr seehofer an seinem
trauma angela merkel und an seinem 2
trauma markus söder ab missbraucht das
bundesinnenministerium als
wahlkampfzentrale der csu
und dann entsteht natürlich ein solches
vakuum in dem einer maßen einfach ein
interview gibt und wir uns dann woche
lang mit diesem unerträglichen gewürge
beschäftigen müssen und ich habe ehrlich
gesagt überhaupt kein verständnis dafür
dass er maßen immer noch am abend ist
ich hatte eigentlich gedacht dass das
vor der bayerischen landtagswahl noch
erledigt wird die assistentin ist der
fall maßen beigelegt oder schwerte es
immer noch aus meiner sicht haben wir
das lange genug diskutiert und sind sehr
viel unsachlichen dingen das wichtige
ist wenn man sagt man will nach
unaufgeregte debatte gehört auch dazu
dass wir uns jetzt einen präsidenten für
das bundesamt für verfassungsschutz
suchen der auch geeignet ist für dieses
amt herr maßen war das der hätte aus
meiner sicht auch im amt bleiben können
auch wenn das interview nicht glücklich
war
aber es wurde vereinbart jetzt von den
koalitionsspitzen dass man sagt
hans-georg maßen besetzt dieses wichtige
amt jetzt so lange weiter bis ein
nachfolger gefunden ist und da wollen
wir jetzt auch nicht irgendeinen
schnellschuss dass man jetzt sagt wir
zaubern jetzt einfach irgendjemanden aus
dem hut sondern da hat horst seehofer
gesagt wird er sich auch in ruhe beraten
es wird dort eine entscheidung geben
aber ich finde gerade in den aufgeregten
zeiten die wir haben wer ist jetzt nicht
sinnvoll gewesen dort einfach einen
schnellschuss zu machen sondern das wird
jetzt geordnet übergeben
warum solltest ein schnellschuss ihrer
meinung nach geben oder ist das gar kein
schneller ist kein schnellschuss sondern
über wochen lang diskutiert wir waren
beide in der innenausschusssitzung
anwesen wo es fünf stunden um die frage
ging wo ist das fehlverhalten und
werbeausgaben aber danach es sei ein
abtritt forderte einheitliche
kommunikationslinie im geschäftsbereich
des bundesministeriums des innern
wir haben eine diskussion und eine
situation in deutschland wo journalisten
angst haben ihre arbeit zu machen
wir haben eine situation wo leute sich
dreimal überlegen ob sie an einer
demonstration teilnehmen wir haben eine
situation wo in bayern 30.000 menschen
auf die straße gehen
gegen ein neues polizeiaufgabengesetz
dann ganz viele jahre in hand mit der
antike
das muss man mal sagen das hat die
maschinen auch geärgert für die fdp das
ist nicht der stil den ich sonst kenne
von euch das recht gilt für alle
es gilt für linke demonstranten es gilt
für rechte demonstranten und es gilt für
demonstranten aus der mitte der
gesellschaft
wenn wir anfangen als die geltung der
grundrechte davon abhängig zu machen ob
jemand ein antifa pullover trägt oder
nicht dann sind wir dem willkürstaat
oder einen solchen stopp ich habe gar
nichts gegen diese versammlung aber man
muss schon sehen dass bayerischen
polizeiaufgabengesetz ist ein gutes
beispiel wenn man darüber diskutiert
diese 30.000 leute die dort dann
zusammen kam in münchen für irgendwelche
demonstrationen da hat man das
bayerischen polizeiaufgabengesetz auch
instrumentalisiert führende das kann ich
nicht anders nennen linke fake news
kampagne an manchen stellen
das war einfach falsch und da habe ich
mich geärgert ich erlebe ich als sehr
ordentliche innenpolitiker das muss ich
sagen von der fdp aber wenn man dann da
hand in hand sag ich mal mit diesem
bewussten falschbehauptungen in münchen
demonstriert das fand ich nicht gerade
glücklich das gab es selbst kommen wir
gleich noch zur herkules wenn sie auch
mal als jurist den blick auf die
entwicklung der rechtslage im bereich
der polizeigesetze werfen
wie fällt denn ihre analyse für die
vergangenen jahre was der
terroristischen bedrohung angeht aus
also wir haben in deutschland
unverändert eine terroristische
bedrohung und angesichts dieser
terroristischen bedrohung und der
verlagerung von kriminalität ins
internet muss es auch zu einer
überarbeitung von befugnissen kommen das
ist völlig klar
man kann nicht sagen eine überarbeitung
von polizei gesetzen kommt gar nicht in
betracht das wäre weltfremd sich so
hinzustellen
man muss sich aber überlegen was sind
eigentlich maßnahmen der polizei
tatsächlich etwas bringen und führt
nicht der übereifer den wir immer wieder
erleben gerade aus cdu und csu nicht
eigentlich zu mehr unsicherheit und das
hat man doch gesehen hat die
vorratsdatenspeicherung drei mal auf die
nase gefallen vom
bundesverfassungsgericht vor dem
europäischen gerichtshof und zuletzt vom
oberverwaltungsgericht in münster
und jetzt haben wir gar keine
vorratsdatenspeicherung also weil man
immer 110 prozent machen will weil man
die bürgerrechte immer zu 100 prozent
beschränken will weil man immer noch
einen schritt weiter gehen will als
konservativer als union als cdu und csu
haben am ende gar keine
vorratsdatenspeicherung wir hätten bei
jamaika ohne weiteres mit den grünen
gemeinsam eine anlassbezogene
speicherung 95 prozent der fälle
beschließen können das wäre gut gewesen
aber es ist eine ideologische
einstellung der cdu und csu weil man
sich das etikett der sicherheit an
heften will und damit wahlkampf machen
will dass man sagt wir müssen immer
alles weitergehen es wäre doch mal schön
weil du gesagt hast die innenpolitik es
ist doch ordentliche innenpolitik wenn
einem die eigenen gesetz nicht alle nase
lang in karlsruhe erschossen werden das
wäre doch gut wenn wir es mal
hinbekommen im deutschen bundestag
gesetze zu machen die auch standhalten
in karlsruhe am bundesverfassungsgericht
und das wäre dann ein schritt mal zu
sagen das was in bayern gemacht worden
ist kann so jedenfalls keine stand
natürlich auch überwiegend so bei den
polizei gesetzen die wir machen und
vorratsdatenspeicherung ist ein gutes
beispiel auch für die aufgeregtheit der
debatte ich bereits vor dieser sendung
heute noch in luxemburg und habe auch am
europäischen gerichtshof über genau
dieses thema auch diskutiert mit
kollegen und es ist natürlich klar dass
das ein völlig falscher diskussions
fotos ist ja bei der
vorratsdatenspeicherung wurde der
eindruck erwecken als hätten wir es hier
mit einem bösen überwachungsstaat zu tun
der nichts anderes zu tun hätte als die
bürger zugängen es geht und das ist uns
das wichtige das wo der fokus stehen
muss in dieser diskussion auch um
datenschutz ist die frage wann können
daten verwertet werden das ist das
eigentlich schlimmer nicht wie werden
daten erhoben denn wenn man sagt man
will eine anlassbezogene
vorratsdatenspeicherung dann ist das für
die betroffenen von denen die daten
gespeichert werden der noch viel tiefere
grundrechtseingriff weil man dann schon
individualisiert also die daten von
allen zu erheben und bei einer gefahr
dann individualisiert auf datenschutz
zu greifen ist viel grundrecht
schonender als wenn man von vornherein
die leute eingrenzt von denen man daten
erhebt und deswegen ist das für uns ein
thema wo man sagt wir brauchen diese
vorratsdatenspeicherung allein wenn ich
an themen denke auch von kriminalitäts
delikten oder wenn wir uns anschauen
auch kinderpornografie andere beispiele
da könnten wir mit der
vorratsdatenspeicherung unsere
sicherheitsbehörden sehr sehr gut
unterstützen
aber ich nehme immerhin jetzt mal auf
dass die fdp sich grundsätzlich dem
nicht versperrt damit brauchen wir
brauchen das wir brauchen die
vorratsdatenspeicherung und zu sagen nur
das erheben von daten die dann geschützt
sind und erst bei einer konkreten gefahr
dann freigegeben werden durch
richterliche anordnung als sei das jetzt
schon das ende des rechtsstaates das
verdeckt dass nicht der staat der
kriminelle ist sondern die bürger die
die straftaten begehen gegen die wir die
daten ermitteln können sie sich das
vorstellen
nein ich kann mir das nicht vorstellen
dass wir das verhältnis von grundrechten
und bürger völlig ins gegenteil
verkehren grundrechte sind dafür da die
bürgerinnen und bürger zu schützen vor
übermäßigen eingriffen des staates und
weil das thema kinderpornographie
angesprochen worden ist warum haben wir
denn keine vorratsdatenspeicherung zur
bekämpfung von kinderpornographie weil
euer gesetzt und jetzt wird als nächstes
ein papier ich habe es gelesen von der
cdu csu vorgelegt wie gesagt wird wir
hätten es gerne auch beim
wohnungseinbruchsdiebstahl alles klar
doch ich gehe immer weiter wird ja aber
wir haben noch nicht mal die
vorratsdatenspeicherung für
terroristische akte und
kinderpornographie neuer ursprungs
gesetz ist nicht verfassungsgemäß und
ihr plan schon den zweiten und dritten
schritt ich meine man muss den ersten
schritt hin bekommen eine anlassbezogene
speicherung regelung war der mann ein
gremium entscheiden lässt bei der man
entscheiden lässt welche anlass welche
personengruppe ist betroffen haben wir
ein besonderes ereignis was
terroristische gefahr ausstrahlt dann
kann man einen bestimmten personenkreis
definieren und dann kann man auch
speichern man kann auch die verdächtigen
oder diejenigen die im bereich
kinderpornografie schon mal sich haben
etwas zuschulden kommen lassen speichern
alles möglich derzeit nicht machbar weil
ihr gesetz verfassungswidrig ist nicht
angewandt werden kann es geht sogar noch
weiter
das oberverwaltungsgericht münster sagt
hier dürfte das ganze nicht anwenden
zu den unternehmen die unternehmen sagen
okay dann lassen wir so speichern die
daten nicht es gibt aber
staatsanwaltschaften die an
telekommunikationsunternehmen
herantreten und sagen jetzt speichert
aber mal die daten zu völliges chaos in
der inneren sicherheit ausgerechnet
organisiert von cdu und csu
glaubst du das macht den polizistinnen
und polizisten spaß gesetze zu haben bei
denen man nicht weiß ob man sie anwenden
kann oder nicht das ist das gegenteil
von russell deswegen optimieren wir das
und deswegen sind wir auch dabei die
vorratsdatenspeicherung unter hochdruck
zu regeln haben das neue papier
vorgelegt dazu und das große problem ist
natürlich immer seminar das thema
besonders stark gemacht und wartet
darauf was gerade ihr fahrrad und ihr
lasst euch da die butter vom brot nehmen
als legislative übergibt das ganze ab
auf die richter wartet dann was
karlsruhe sagt und dann wird genau das
abgeschrieben was gerade zu sagen das
hat mit legislativen selbst gemacht und
in der tat ist es natürlich so das
widerspricht sich sehr diese
argumentation ja einerseits sagst du ihr
produzierten verfassungswidriges gesetz
was sozusagen immer möglich ist das muss
man sagen das gehört mehr oder minder
zum betriebsrisiko es gab auch und der
fdp innenministern oder von fdp und ist
dann genug gesetze die karlsruhe
verwirft das ist nunmal betriebsrisiko
von politik man arbeite darauf nicht hin
wir haben auch die
vorratsdatenspeicherung nicht geregelt
um verfassungswidriges gesetz zu
produzieren sondern das war das dann das
ergebnis das setzen wir auch um und in
der situation gerade wenn du sagst ist
es wichtig auch zuhören darauf was
karlsruher sagt es ist auch richtig die
jetzige entscheidung abzuwarten und das
sozusagen noch als hintergrund zu nehmen
bis dahin muss man sehen die lösung die
ihr vorschlag mit der anlassbezogenen
vorratsdatenspeicherung ist die viel
kompliziertere und viel aufwendiger als
die anlasslose vorratsdatenspeicherung
bezirk das ist auch in ordnung so und
das sehen wir auch aber ist es nach wie
vor klar
wir verstehen sowohl die entscheidung
vom bundesverfassungsgericht als auch
den europäischen gerichtshof so dass
auch eine anlasslose
vorratsdatenspeicherung möglich ist und
diese rechtssicher zu konstruieren
machen wir aber das geht eben immer nur
gegen riesigen öffentlichen druck denn
man hat manchmal den eindruck dass das
schlimme die verdächtigen sozusagen der
staat ist der irgendwie daten von
kriminellen erheben will unter
richtervorbehalt und als wenn das das
schlimmste sein und ich glaube da es
insbesondere bei diesen datenschutz
grundrechten manches aus dem lot geraten
auch in der innenpolitischen
argumentation es geht niemanden darum
die leute anlasslos zu überwachen
sondern es geht darum konkret bezogen
aufgefahren
unseren rechtsstaat wehrhaft und
einsatzfähig zu machen an und daran
arbeiten die alles richtig aber dafür
müssen richterinnen und richter die
technischen voraussetzungen
beispielsweise des staatstrojaners
verstehen wenn ich frage als
abgeordneter im deutschen bundestag wie
funktioniert der staatstrojaner
wie ist die abgrenzung zwischen quellen
telekommunikationsüberwachung und online
durchsuchungen dann sagt mir das
bundesministerium des innern
das können wir nicht sagen aus gründen
des staats wohl ist wie ist es dann bei
richterinnen und richtern die diesen
staatstrojaner anordnen sollen erfahren
die dann auch nicht wir technisch
funktioniert bei jeder blitzer kontrolle
bei jedem knöllchen dass ich bekomme
wegen zu schnellem fahren ist in der
akte ein zertifikat über die
funktionsweise aus neutraler sicht des
blitzers und beim staatstrojaner
produziert der staat selber
sicherheitslücken und verlässt sich
darauf dass man schon irgendeine richter
entscheiden und gibt dem richter dann
aber keine möglichkeit das ganze
technisch zu verstehen und ich
prognostiziere das kann in dieser form
in karlsruhe keinen bestand haben und
ich will eine frage zurückstellen weil
ich den vorschlag hervorragend stunde zu
warten auf bestimmte er war auf
bestimmte geschichten aus karlsruhe ich
habe wie gesagt ein problem mit dem link
steven selbstbewusstsein an der stelle
aber man kann das natürlich auch machen
ob dieses betriebs risiko zu minimieren
warum machen wir das nicht mehr muster
polizeigesetz warten wir doch bei muster
polizeigesetz auf die entscheidung aus
karlsruhe zum staatstrojaner und auf die
sich anbahnende entscheidung zur
präventivhaft zwei geschichten dem
karlsruher jetzt anhängig sind und da
können wir mal muster polizeigesetz
warten und das land entsprechend
verfassungsgemäß ausgestalten
ich will ich das an der stelle nur kurz
mal aufklären da liegt nicht an uns
beiden zu warten sondern wie du weißt
wird es muss der polizei gesetzt nicht
nur im deutschen bundestag beschlossen
weil es kein bundesgesetz ist weil wir
für die länder dagegen sondern das
machen die innenminister miteinander es
gibt diese arbeitsgruppe das behandeln
die 16 landesinnenminister und da wird
es eine orientierung geben und da wird
es auch um diese themen gehen um andere
aktive cyberkrieg achter mit bundestags
am tisch und ganz wichtiger punkt das
bka gesetz ist an vielen stellen die
blaupause was muss der polizei hat das
lager ja selber ist deswegen hat das
ganze schon bundespolitische relevanz
und ganz viel diskutierte sollte das
muss das kleine raten im plenum des
deutschen bundestages diskutieren so das
gehört doch schauen wir da und geben im
innenausschuss aber wie das von der form
ist wird dann gesehen am ende kommt es
darauf an dass die länder kooperieren
unternehmen schauen wir doch
auf ein land herrn tur bayern hat ja das
sogenannte polizeiaufgabengesetz gerade
das land geschlossen
da gibt es allerdings heftige kritik in
bayern die demonstration haben wir die
bilder mehr alle gesehen von den
demonstrationen die es da gibt wie
würden sie denn sagen beschreitet hier
bayern voran oder geht bayern einen ganz
anderen weg also ich finde die
diskussion ums bayerischen
polizeiaufgabengesetz ist einfach völlig
emotional überhöht also am ende
man hat sich nicht entschieden dieses
polizeiaufgabengesetz zu machen um
irgendwie den bürger am gängelband zu
führen sondern es geht um zwei themen
die dort im vordergrund stehen das ist
vor allem das thema terrorismus und das
ist das thema neuer gefahren auch aus
dem cyber raum und das sind beides
probleme bei denen es nicht aufzuwarten
ankommt sondern wo man auch aktiv sein
muss und ich finde es besonders
bemerkenswert wenn man jetzt sieht durch
den neuen gefahren begriff der im
bayerischen polizeiaufgabengesetz
definiert wird als sei das jetzt das
schlimme und als könne man jetzt wenn
man irgendwie bei facebook postet und
morgen mache ich ein graffiti an die
bayerische staatskanzlei als würde dann
eine halbe stunde später das sek vor der
tür stehen das sind ja so die bilder die
da gezeichnet werden unterm strich
dieser gefährder begriff und der
gefahren begriff der besser der gefahren
begriff vom bayerischen
polizeiaufgabengesetz setzt eigentlich
nur eines um was im polizeirecht schon
im prinzip seit 100 jahren normale
dogmatik ist das sozusagen
je größer die gefahr ist dass desto
weniger die wahrscheinlichkeit sozusagen
für den gefahren eintritt da sein muss
das heißt spezialisiertes dieser neue
gefahren begriff insbesondere auf
terroristische gefahren und es geht vor
allem jetzt darum auf große und
spezielle lagen sich einzustellen gerät
steht ist aber nicht drin
ja das ist dabei so wie es auszulegen
ist und es ist auch völlig klar
da gab es genug diskussion auch ich habe
mir die expertenanhörung im bayerischen
landtag da angesehen auch die gutachten
angeschaut unterm strich geht es darum
dass man ein prinzip dass es schon lange
im polizeirecht gibt nämlich diese
gefahrenprognose formel dass man die ein
stück weit verrechtlicht und ich glaube
diese großen sorgen die man sich dort
macht die sind an vielen stellen
unberechtigt dass bayerischen
polizeiaufgabengesetz ist sehr
fortschrittlich es wird ja auch dort
anhängige klagen geben
ich kann nur sagen ich sehe den
entscheidungen über die
verfassungsmäßigkeit des p ag relativ
gelassen entgegen glaube dass das
bestätigt wird und ich bin froh dass es
mit joachim herrmann und mit der csu in
bayern auch eine regierung gibt die sich
dieser neuen herausforderung des
terrorismus und der gefahren aus dem
cyber raum auch aktiv annimmt weil das
ist bitter nötig die größte gefahr für
den rechtsstaat ist nämlich nicht das
neue bayerische polizei gesetzt sondern
die größte gefahr wäre es für meinen
diesen neuen herausforderungen keine
antworten in dole wie sehen sie das denn
der frühere innenminister gerhart baum
wird csu vor dass er hier dass hier
politik mit der angst gemacht wird weil
so sieht das ähnlich sehen oder finden
sie das gesetz auch gut also dass gerade
diese beiden geschichten die nicht
länger nach ausspielen die bekämpfung
von terrorismus und die bekämpfung von
kriminalität was machen wir um unsere
grundwerte zu verteidigen um den schutz
der körperlichen unversehrtheit zu
verteidigen um dazu beizutragen dass
unsere menschen in deutschland sich
sicher fühlen und zu diesen werten die
wir verteidigen gehört aber auch die
privatsphäre gehört auch die
informationelle selbstbestimmung das ist
teil des wertekanons und teil der
grundrechte die wir miteinander in
deutschland verteidigen und in bayern
auch keiner ab nun ist es so dass in
bayern mit der drohenden gefahr ein
hohes risiko eingegangen wird denn die
drohende gefahr die ist in der tat schon
gibt nämlich im urteil zum bka gesetz
bezieht sich dort aber alleine auf
überwachungsmaßnahmen und nicht auf
eingriffs maße natürlich ist eine
eingriffs maßnahme wie die lebenslange
präventivhaft wie sie jetzt alleine
bayern im polizeiaufgabengesetz regelt
eine ganz scharfe eingriffs maßnahme und
niemand weiß ob das verfassungsgemäß ist
aber es gibt bestimmte indizien die
darauf hindeuten lassen das ist das
nicht ist und diese indizien sind cdu
geführte landesregierung die das eben
nicht machen wie in nrw wo mit der fdp
gemeinsam nach der expertenanhörung im
landtag erscheint irgendwie andere
experten gewesen zu sein
herausgekommen ist das eine lebenslange
präventivhaft und nicht mal eine
präventivhaft 30 tage mit diesen
voraussetzungen geht wie die
landesregierung in niedersachsen die ein
gesetz durchdrücken will mit 74 tagen
präventivhaft obwohl nach vier tagen
anhörung herausgekommen ist dass das mit
diesen gefahren begriff unter diesen
voraussetzungen nicht geht also entweder
geht nur in bayern tatsächlich anders in
puncto verfassungsrecht was ich mir
nicht wünschen würde dann auch dort gilt
das grundgesetz oder die cdu schafft es
schlichtweg nicht durch die von ihr
betreuten landesministerien erinnern die
innere sicherheit zu organisieren der 30
also diese präventivhaft diese wird
nicht erhalten bleiben ich will auch
noch ein wort zur csu sagen weil sie
herrn baumann gesprochen haben die art
und weise wie herr herrmann wie auch
kollegen aus dem innenausschuss von der
csu aus dem deutschen bundestag auf
diese 30.000 menschen die sich sorgen
und ihre bürger und freiheitsrechte
machen reagiert haben das zeigt doch
genau die arroganz der macht der csu in
bayern und ich hoffe dass das am
kommenden sonntag auch die wählerinnen
und wähler bewegt da spielt jetzt
vielleicht nur kurz sagen weil die
bayerischen oder die falschen
landesregierung angesprochen sind wir
sind dann natürlich auch in
unterschiedlichen konstellationen und
ich finde wenn man nordrhein-westfalen
anspricht dann hat herbert reul dass ein
minister da auch ganz vernünftig
moderiert und sicherlich ist es so das
gehört eben dazu dass man 16
unterschiedliche polizeigesetze hat dass
es dort auch unterschiedlich scharfe
regelungen gibt ich glaube persönlich
und das zeigt der wortbeitrag wenn man
sich jetzt auf die präventivhaft so
fokussiert man tut ja geradezu so als
hätte man in bayern jetzt die intention
leute wegen nichtigkeiten irgendwie
leben lang einzusperren das ist
natürlich völliger unsinn darum geht es
nicht sondern es geht im kern um ganz
andere regelungen schwerpunkte des
polizeiaufgabengesetz und viele kollegen
in der csu haben sich natürlich zu recht
darüber geärgert dass versucht wird eben
mit solchen geschichten zu sagen ja
jetzt kann jeder anlasslos überwacht
werden oder jeder kann jetzt ohne
gefahrenverdacht unbegrenzt eingesperrt
werden das mit sowas einfach auch angst
geschürt wird von linker seite und das
akzeptieren wir auch nicht und deswegen
muss man auch sagen natürlich gilt das
grundgesetz und gelten die von dir
angesprochenen grundrechte in bayern
ganz genauso und die bayerische polizei
wird das auch berücksichtigen und selbst
wegen wird seine verfassung ist schon
gerne noch an einer stelle handhabe
geben
bisher war aber einfach noch mal kurz
nachfragen da geht es noch mal um den
begriff der gefahr den sie hier
angesprochen haben früher hieß es dass
eine konkrete gefahr bestehen muss jetzt
steht er in eine drohende gefahr können
sie uns doch mal darüber aufklären wo da
der unterschied ist und wo man jetzt
angreifen kann wo man vorher eingreifen
konnte nun ja der unterschied ist zum
beispiel das kann man an einem fall
recht deutlich machen wenn man sich zum
beispiel vorstellt es gibt ein ehepaar
das miteinander im streit lag und der
mann ist dann in großer rage und postet
bei facebook jetzt werde ich morgen
meine frau umbringen
dann ist das zumindest nach jetzigem
polizeirecht ist das keine konkrete
gefahr weil man dann sagt okay das ist
alles noch nicht hinreichend
konkretisiert und da gibt es sozusagen
jetzt juliane vermeintliche
absichtserklärung und mit dem begriff
der drohenden gefahr würde es uns in der
konstellation möglich sein auch polizei
rechtliche maßnahmen wie meine
observationsaufgaben man sich diesem
fall anschaut zeigt es dass das ziemlich
sinnvoll ist auch hier mit neuen
operationen auch in das vorfeld
sozusagen von gefahren vor zu verlagern
da geht es vor allem also um anstellen
darf ich eine frage zu dem konkreten
beispiel stellt hast du nicht gerade
gesagt dass es bei der drohenden
gefahren nur um terrorismus geht jetzt
aber ist ein gerade gespielt das hat
nichts mit terrorismus zu tun also
häuslicher gewalt ist schlimm und wir
haben gerade in dieser sei aber die
morgen polizeigesetz zumindest
hinreichen aber es ist kein trainer ralf
gefahren und damit zeigst du genau den
mechanismus der an diesem polizeigesetz
zu kritisieren dass wir führend apple
immer weitere freiheitsbeschränkungen
einen wie den staatstrojaner und dann
fragt die fdp fraktion wird denn der
staatstrojaner tatsächlich für
terroristische delikte verwendet und
dann sagt das bmbf bundesministerium des
innern
naja also vereinigung der für
drogendelikte verwendet jetzt sind
drogendelikte schlimm genauso wie wenn
jemand seine frau umbringt aber es ist
eine frage der legitimation staatlichen
handelns der man sagt wir machen etwas
wegen terrorismus und dann setzt man
plötzlich ein beispiel in die welt wo es
um häusliche gewalt das hat erst mal
wenig miteinander und das sei die
drohende gefahr ist uferlos die gefahr
dass tatsächlich diese gesetze die
eigentlich für den termin ismus
ausgelegt sind auch auf andere
straftaten angriff
in der großen jagd aber wenn man dieses
beispiel sieht was wäre denn lieber dass
man sagt die polizei kann nichts tun
zwei schaut zu das ist der fall wir
haben
ich will jetzt mal deutlich machen um
die augen und ressourcen oder war ich
die ganze zeit gesagt zu schneien
damit war generalklausel überhaupt nicht
es geht wenig das wollen wir nicht
sondern es geht darum dass wir
insbesondere neue tag vorm aus dem
internet in den blickpunkt nehmen du
hast angesprochen den den kölner favorit
des distrikts - falls dort wo sozusagen
ein terroristischer gefährde eine re
ziehen
das bundesamt für verfassungsschutz
hatte diesen jungen mann da diesen
gefährder vor augen und was konnte man
machen und man hat eine und man hat eine
online wo genau und jetzt alle quellen
ticker ja und pass auf und was was
passiert man hat eine observation
angeordnet und man hat diesen gefährder
dort observiert und es stand ein
polizeiauto dann mal vor der tür
verdeckte ermittler
die haben dann den beobachtet und das
eigentliche was aber passiert die
tatmittel diese rizinus sagen da ist ja
nicht aus der haustür gegangen und hat
die irgendwie gekauft sondern die hat ja
im internet bestellt und das konnte
unser bv weil sich die politik zu sehr
sträubt gegen diese kompetenzen konnte
da nichts machen und wir sind dankbar
dass über die internationalen kontakte
von hans-georg maßen es dann ein hinweis
von einem befreundeten dienst gab der in
der lage war diese internet aktivitäten
zu überwachen dass da mal jemand gesagt
hat er bestellt aber irgendwie
verdächtige dinge dort und das zeigt
doch so sehr wie notwendig es ist dass
wir diese neuen gefahren auch aktiv
bekämpfen können und ich möchte dass
sowohl in dem fall von dem ich
gesprochen habe mit dem ehemann dass man
dort dann auch mal sagen kann was
passiert da jetzt eigentlich und genau
so möchte ich das in dem fall dieses
rizinus anschlages auch unsere polizei
und unsere nachrichtendienste dort in
die lage versetzt werden auf solche
gefahren zu reagieren alles andere ist
blauäugig wenn man sich vergegenwärtigt
gericht anschaut dann wird ja da
eigentlich die möglichkeit eröffnet dass
man bei drohender gefahr tatsächlich
einschreitet von daher ist letztendlich
dieses polizeiaufgabengesetz nicht doch
einfach nur die maßgabe die das
verfassungsgericht auch vor
das gericht macht keine maß gaben was
für eine gesetzgebung zu erfolgen hat
nur in ganz seltenen fällen die maßgabe
und erklärte abwägung die wir machen als
politik das müssen die politikerinnen
und politiker selber entscheiden und da
müssen wir uns selber eine werte
diskussion darüber führen wie man das im
innenausschuss und bildung des deutschen
bundestages macht und dann kann wenn
jemand betroffen ist diese personen
vorgehen dagegen im wege der
verfassungsbeschwerde aber das müssen
schon politiker machen sie müssen darauf
kommen ich will noch heute das beispiel
aufgreifen das ist ja so was tragen
beispiel in nrw genannt hast in
nordrhein westfalen gerät aber was
bayerischen polizeiaufgabengesetz es
gibt offensichtlich verschwunden braucht
man dann wohl in allen ländern das mama
warum ich aussehen das dann nicht in
nordrhein-westfalen vielleicht weil sie
mit der fdp darauf achten und das mir
gesagt das ist eine mehrheit haben ja
das ist das vielleicht damit zu tun
also ich glaube dass eine solche
diskussion dass eine über das jahr
gesehen das ist eine eine schleichende
erosion der freiheitsrechte die wir
erleben es wird erst gesagt na ja es
geht ja nur um terrorismus dann kommt
die einfache kriminalität dazu dann
kommt das internet dazu dann werden
beispiele genannt wo unsere
strafverfolgungsbehörden grund unsere
polizei gute arbeit gemacht haben bei
dieser fall gelöst worden ist und dann
wird mit einer situation ein nationalist
ansprechen ohne online-durchsuchungen
ohne quellen ticker wird ein solcher
anschlag verhindert und dann sagst du
das heißt gerade eineinhalb moment ist
und was einfach für das passt aber davon
nur noch mal kann ich nur empfehlen sich
mit dem konkreten fall zu beschäftigen
wir hätten deshalb diesen wir hätten
diesen terroranschlag vielleicht in
unserem land erleben müssen wenn wir
nicht von befreundeten dienst den
hinweis dafür bekommen welche maßnahme
an welcher mann passierte es dann es
handelte sich aber dem typen in köln um
einen gefährde haben der unter
beobachtung des bundesamtes für
verfassungsschutz oder des landesamtes
stand das weiß ich nicht mehr
das verfassungsschutz verbunden ist das
heißt wir haben die gefährte einstufung
gehabt welche maßnahme von denen eben
diskutierten wäre dann erforderlich
gewesen um das ganze zu machen wenn ich
sage dass wir speicherung und
überwachung und observationsaufgaben bei
drohender gefahr vom
bundesverfassungsgericht zugelassen dass
eingriffe nicht ob situation schon dann
können wir das auch anlassbezogen für
gefährder regeln dass es dort einen vor
eine eine vorherige prüfung gibt dass
wir eine verfassungsgemäße quellen tk
über meinetwegen hinbekommen bei der wir
technisch überprüfen ob das ganze
funktioniert aber mit dem holzhammer
aus bayern kommen wir am ende dazu
lassen gar keine maßnahmen möglich sind
wir kommen dazu dass ein einbruch
stattfindet in die freiheitsrechte und
immer neue delikte gesucht werden
gefunden werden also dass wir zu euch
gesagt wenn man sich fragt was uns fehlt
hilft es mal einen blick zu werfen über
den tellerrand zu befreundeten
nachrichtendiensten wie machen die denn
das und was ist die lösung die lösung
ist ein kreuz abgleich von datenbanken
denn man sollte sich folgendes
vorstellen und das wäre gut für einen
modernen nachrichtendienst wenn man sich
vorstellt es gibt jemanden der bestellte
im internet in großer zahl rizinus samen
und der google dann vorher noch den an
die anleitung für den bau einer bombe
und derselbe typ der das alles macht der
steht dann als gefährder wegen
islamistischer kontakte noch in
irgendeiner datenbank da wäre es schon
sinnvoll wenn man das miteinander
abgrenzen abgleichen könnte doch schon
aber das macht nichts falsch
befreundeten aber dieses versuchen weil
dann funktioniert es dann geht irgendwo
das lämpchen an und da wird gezeigt der
chipkonzerne gefahr sein und so müsste
unser rechtsstaat darauf was muss noch
nicht haben doch etwas anfangen sondern
bei dem gefährt ich muss mich erst mal
fragen wer ist der gescherer und dann
kann ich den überwachen aber nicht alle
überwachen oder gucken wir mal wer ist
da gefährde das durch die nadel in
europa sagen doch die
sicherheitsbehörden selber dass sie
solche fragen überhaupt nicht ich war
hat die polizei in der halle selber
gesagt die uferlose ausdehnung
wenn ich da noch mal fragen darf wo wir
beim thema gefahr noch mal sind wir für
die gerne noch mal ein bisschen nach
nachfragen
sie haben das ja eben auseinander
gedrosselt mit konkreter gefahr und
drohender gefahr
wer definiert letztendlich denn was eine
drohende gefahr ist wenn sie dieses
beispiel von von der frau dort nehmen
beziehungsweise ein man könne nicht an
sie können nicht anders einem ort
stattfinden soll
wer definiert dann letztendlich das ist
jetzt eine drohende gefahr wurde
eingreifen und wenn nicht das ist immer
dann die konkrete entscheidung der
ausführenden polizei oder
nachrichtendienst behörde und das ist im
prinzip insoweit nichts neues deswegen
sage ich wir haben das seit 100 jahren
im polizeirecht wir haben immer und das
ist das besondere das als der es uns war
ja das ist es und in der tat und das ist
ja gerade das besondere vom polizeirecht
und vom nachrichtendienst recht dass es
eben präventiv sozusagen gefahr
ein abwehrrecht ist und das heißt es ist
immer eine prognoseentscheidung es ist
anders wenn ich jetzt als staatsanwalt
irgendwie am schreibtisch sitzen die
lage rekonstruiere dann habe ich die
zeit kann das bewerten aber als polizist
als polizeiführer als führer
nachrichtendienst von von der von der
operation muss sich immer eine
entscheidung und der ungewissheit
treffen und da muss ich eine
güterabwägung vornehmen
und da müssen wir dann natürlich auch
das rüstzeug geben dass diese
güterabwägung auch auf neue gefahren
herausforderungen eingehen kann weil ich
will dass an einer stelle noch sagen wir
können natürlich bei hinreichender
gefahr können wir heute beispielsweise
in einer wohnung eindringen wenn es
notwendig ist wir können heute sachen
beschlagnahmen und wir können sogar
gefährliche dinge zerstören
im internet geht das alles nicht also
mit derselben begründung sagt man dann
bei hinreichender bei gleicher
vielleicht sogar bei größerer gefahr
terroristischer gefahren
soll man im internet dann nicht
eindringen können soll man im internet
nicht dinge zerstören können aktiv
angreifen können das ist für mich und
vor allem für viele bürger im land doch
nicht nachvollziehbar wir können doch
hier nicht offen lücken lassen in
unserer gefahrenabwehr sondern da müssen
wir uns auch einstellen auf neue
herausforderungen dass man die lehrerin
einer cola aber in nrw sollte und ein
polizeiaufgabengesetz ganz ähnlicher
form verabschiedet werden die fdp es
dort mit in der regierung
die fdp wird aber zustimmen ja und zwar
weil es erhebliche unterschiede zu
bayern gibt 30 tage präventivhaft
maximal stadt und endlichkeit haft keine
online durchsuchung in nrw online
durchsuchung in bayern eine debatte nach
der anhörung im landtag wie kann man den
begriff der drohenden gefahr hinreichend
konkretisieren um das merkmal
terroristisch denn das ist genau der
punkt der die nicht wohin meinte als ich
sagte ich glaube wir reden müssen
einander vorbei du sprichst über die
konkrete anwendung des rechts und
natürlich müssen wir uns darauf
verlassen dass polizeibeamte in ihrer
guten ausbildung wir haben das sehr
reflektierte polizeiausbildung in
deutschland lernen wie man das recht
anwendet und da sind wir auch dankbar
dass wir so eine gute polizei haben es
gibt aber auch eine abwägung eine
güterabwägung die nicht die polizei
sondern die vorher gesetz geht unser
treffen
wenn du richtig sagt eine güterabwägung
hat stattzufinden
durch den polizisten durch die
polizeibeamten die vor ort tätig ist
dann muss ihr jemand doch vorhersagen
welche bücher sie eigentlich genau
abwägen zeugen und das ist der
gesetzgeber das ist die legislative und
da sind wir gefragt reinzuschreiben was
meinen wir eigentlich und da standen wir
in nrw vor der frage nehmen wir die
drohende gefahr uferlos teilweise
wahrscheinlich verfassungswidrig
bundesverfassungsgericht bka-gesetz oder
konkretisieren wir es mit blick auf
terrorismus mit guter zusammenarbeit mit
der cdu würde mir wünschen dass die cs
gut einmal sich noch schneller
abschneidet und das vielleicht auch mal
so machen wir das passt überhaupt nicht
zusammen unverständlich und am ende dort
ein gesetz auf die straße gebracht bei
dem am ende die experten immer noch
gesagt haben das geht zu weit und jetzt
wird's noch mal angefasst weil das ein
thema ist das uns wichtig ist weil die
grundrechte der bürgerinnen und bürger
zur disposition stehen und weil das ist
ein aspekt der mir extrem wichtig ist
wie auch im internationalen vergleich
mal gucken müssen was eigentlich mit den
grundrechten so passiert wir reden wenn
er hinten stehen wird und seine polizei
kompetenzen da aber im internationalen
förder dass wir international den
rechtsstaat unsere grundrecht unser
grundgesetz als exportschlager haben
aber das ist staaten geht es auch gut
sich sehr genau gucken dass es
menschenrechtler gibt die sehr genau
gucken wie wird eigentlich in
deutschland über etwas diskutiert wie
upload filter wie das netzwerk
durchsetzungs gesetz die freiheit im
internet und dann habe ich staaten wie
die türkei wo twitter geblockt ist wo
wikipedia geblockt ich habe im iran
immer mehr menschen die auf die straße
planten nicht mehr nach csu vor als
lebensgroße aber überhaupt einfluss bei
dem traditionellen vergleich auch mal
gucken müssen sind wir mit unserem
schutz der grundrechte und der freiheit
im internet noch der sozusagen
tonangebende faktor und wir haben doch
eine janocha diskussion momentan die
bestimmt wird durch einen herrn trump
mit angriffen auf die judikative mit mit
einem herrn putin ja der
menschenrechtler ins gefängnis gesperrt
und dazwischen ist die kleine
europäische union wo es noch einen
einzelnen staat gibt in dem das thema
privatsphäre und datenschutz besonders
hoch gehängt wurde
bei uns will doch keiner putin und bei
uns will auch keiner schwamb und gleicht
damit auch eigentlich das ist ein
argumentationsmuster dass wir immer
wieder werden nämlich freiheit und
sicherheit gegeneinander auszuspielen
und das ist für mich nicht akzeptabel ja
die freiheit gibt es ja die frage
gestellt werden dass inwiefern das
sicherheitsthema von dem populisten auch
in irgendeiner form wirklich ausgenutzt
und missbraucht wird dieser gesellschaft
ist das so
und ja natürlich und naja die antwort
muss doch sein dass wir zeigen dass
dieser staat willens und in der lage ist
auch konsequent recht durchzusetzen das
ist das was im alltag bei uns passiert
aber auch access fälle die wir immer
wieder sehen darauf müssen wir antworten
haben und ich glaube dass wir durch
aktuelle bedrohungslagen das wäre doch
wasser auf die mühlen der populisten
stellen sie sich mal vor wie die afg uns
am nasenring durch die manege gezogen
hätte wenn wir nicht in befreundeten
dienst gehabt hätten der uns bei diesem
kölner fall die hinweise gegeben hätte
sondern wenn da ein anschlag passiert
wäre und sich wir wir als innenpolitiker
uns hingestellt hätten und gesagt hätten
tja wir hatten zwar den den beamten
observierten vor der tür stehen aber ins
internet konnten wir nicht gucken und
wir konnten das alles gar nicht sehen
und deswegen ist dieser anschlag
passiert deswegen ist die beste antwort
auf populismus und gerade auf die
populisten diese sicherheitsthema
angreifen eben objektiv sicherheit zu
gewährleisten und dafür brauchen wir
auch für neue gefahren szenarien neue
befugnisse
das ist da würde ich gerne noch mal
anschließend heute eben gesagt dieses
gegeneinander ausspielen von freiheit
und sicherheit wäre gefährlich wo oder
wäre schwierig wo müssen wir denn da
schlussstrich ziehen wenn es um freiheit
oder um sicherheit geht also ist das
höhere gut in dem fall
natürlich müssen güter gegeneinander
abgewogen werden und die freiheiten die
im grundgesetz normiert sind helfen uns
zunächst einmal dabei als freie menschen
zu leben und uns auch zu verteidigen
gegen grundrechtseingriffe die vom staat
ausgehen das ist eine ganz wichtige
grundierung dieser werteordnung die wir
haben und das hilft uns eben auch dabei
dieser staat geworden zu sein diese
gesellschaft auf die man ein stück weit
auch für seine rechtsstaatlichkeit für
seine grundrechte für den respekt vor
der arbeit der sicherheitsbehörden
worauf man auch stolz
kann und das ist alles nicht von
ungefähr gekommen sondern das kommt auch
daher dass man sich sehr genau überlegt
wie viel darf eigentlich der staat und
ich will da für mich und ich will
eigentlich nicht erleben dass wir und
ich kann hass gegröle und gejohle der
afb dann genauso vorstellen dass wir ein
gesetz machen zur unendlichkeit haft in
bayern dass man verfassungswidrig ist
und am ende müssen wir alle frei
gelassen werden heuer gesetz wieder
krass uns gemäß
das ist aber dass sich auszumalen gut
der jurist um zu wissen dass es da eine
übergangsregelung geben würde und ich
bin sicher dass das nicht passieren wird
dass man das gesetz nicht kippen wird
und wir reden von präventivhaft auf die
präventivhaft das ist kein dauerzustand
wird eine richtige anordnung folge
das ist doch quatsch es wird doch in
bayern nicht eine situation kommen das
ist doch das kann sich in einer guten
starts 1070 sagen warum sie endlich in
bayern warum kann ich mich verhalten zu
hören super da brauchen wir nicht über
30 tage präventivhaft weil in bayern
wird so passieren wenn es eine
präventivhaft gibt wird es eine
einzelfall entscheidungen dann wird
richtig schnell danach eine
haftanordnung folgen mit seiner
konkreten aussagen na ja das kommt auf
den konkreten einzelfall an
ich glaube nicht dass man das jetzt
sagen sie jetzt in tagen beschränken
kann ich und diese das ist doch
populismus beim wild sein dann werden
alle entlassen dann tut man ja so als
wären dann zum zeitpunkt irgendeine
entscheidung in karlsruhe bayern
hunderte gefährdeten präventiv auf das
wird nicht passieren wenn es eine
präventivhaft anordnung in bayern gibt
dann werden sie bayerischen
sicherheitsbehörden dafür arbeiten dass
diese präventivhaft dann mit einem
konkretisierten haftgrund umgewandelt
wird und ich will
wir sind aber fast am schluss der
sendung haben ich würde gerne noch einen
schluss frage steiner hatte christa cent
mehr klar inwieweit opfern wir oder
müssen wir wirklich freiheit für unsere
sicherheit opfern
wir müssen freiheit nicht für unsere
sicherheit opfern sondern es gehört
beides zusammen weil beides hat ja
denselben bezugspunkt und das ist das
was mich immer so ein bisschen an dieser
argumentation stört wenn man sagt der
übermächtige böse staat der die
sicherheit durchsetzen will
sicherheit ist für uns doch kein
selbstzweck wir wollen nicht
vorratsdatenspeicherung oder daten
erheben damit das bka eine möglichst
volle festplatte hat sondern wir machen
das und wir wollen sicherheit
gewährleisten um eben grundrechte zu
schützen und nämlich die grundrechte von
gefährdeten bürgern
schützen und um unserer unseren
sicherheitsversprechen ein staat
nachzukommen und insoweit sicherheit hat
für uns ja kein selbstzweck sondern
sicherheit es eben auch schutz von
grundrechten und freiheit und sicherheit
das ist kein widerspruch sondern das
bedingt einander das ist immer eine
abwägungsentscheidung und wir wollen
nicht einfach zum selbstzweck den
starken start aber wir wollen einen
wehrhaften staat der auf die aktuellen
herausforderungen antworten kann dafür
müssen wir noch ein bisschen was tun und
wir arbeiten daran und manchmal sind wir
auch auf einem guten weg so sehr wie
viel freiheit geben wir auch für unsere
sicherheit in einem wehrhaften staat
muss die politik die sicherheitsbehörden
in die lage versetzen die gesellschaft
und den staat zu verteidigen gegen
angriffe krimineller natur
terroristischer natur aber da darf man
nicht die eigene werteordnung hinten
anstellen auch privatsphäre auch
informationelle selbstbestimmung auch
die freiheit der menschen gehört zu
unserer werteordnung auch so etwas wie
die unschuldsvermutung gehört dazu und
ausgerechnet in einer so angespannten
lage wie wir sie momentan in deutschland
haben ist die cdu und die csu nicht in
der lage die innere sicherheit in
deutschland zu organisieren weil
verfassungswidrige polizeigesetze
gemacht werden weil wir die geschichte
um ein maßen erlebt haben und das ist
eine situation das sind wirklich
schlechte nachrichten für in der
sicherheit in deutschland statt dessen
sollten wir den föderalismus angehen
sollten uns mal fragen ob er wirklich 16
landesämter für verfassungsschutz
brauchen und sollten investieren in
personal auch in sachliche ausstattung
und in einem guten dialog auch einen
kritischen dialog mit den
sicherheitsbehörden dazu beitragen dass
wir weiter stolz auf sie sein können ich
bedanke mich bei ihnen beiden für die
sehr engagierte diskussion das zeigt
dass dieses thema doch gut ist wenn man
sich in der öffentlichkeit dann auch mal
so detailliert diskutiert vielen
herzlichen dank und ich bedanke mich bei
ihnen fürs zuschauen
[Applaus]
[Musik]